[Music]
Michael B Jordan blew away audiences
with his ferocious and nuanced portrayal
of Eric kilmonger Stevens in 2008's
Black Panther with the character quickly
skyrocketing into the upper tier of
Marvel Cinematic Universe villains
kilmonger famously died at the
conclusion of that film after uttering
one of the most badass lines in film
history bury me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jump from the
ships cuz they knew death was better
than bondage but that has stopped fans
from wondering if he might make a return
after all in the MCU as in the pages of
Marvel Comics a character's death does
not necessarily mean the end black
panther earned more than a billion
dollars at the worldwide box office and
became a cultural phenomenon writer
director Ryan cougler along with stars
Leticia Wright Martin Freeman and Angela
Basset are all on board for the sequel
planned for 2022 of course the tragic
death of star Chadwick Boseman following
a secret 4-year battle with colon can
has left the franchise without its title
star boseman's passing has prompted all
manner of intense speculation about the
future of black panther 2 and instantly
reignited the debate over whether
Jordan's magnetic killmonger could
return to help Revitalize the franchise
it's worth noting that we never actually
saw kilmonger expire on screen he was
Gravely injured after his final brawl
with King tchala who offered to attempt
to save his life using wakanda's Ultra
Advanced Medical Technology maybe we can
still heal you
what and though kilmonger asked to be
buried at Sea tala appears from a
distance to possibly apply some sort of
emergency treatment to his wound it
could perhaps be a vibranium disc like
the one that was earlier used to
stabilized to chala's CIA Ally Everett
Ross even if kilmonger succumbing to his
injuries was seemingly imminent wakandan
Tech is a wondrous thing its March of
progress never ceases and we know that
cryostasis has been perfected Ed as
we've seen it used on Bucky Barnes or
white wolf as he's known in wakanda
could kilmonger have been put on Ice
until such time as Medical Science could
save him kilmonger could also return
without actually physically returning
having partaken of the heartshaped herb
to gain the power of the Black Panther
in the first movie it seems possible
that his Spirit could now reside along
with that of tala's father King tachaka
and the other black panthers of yor on
the ancestral plane here he could offer
singular unique guidance and advice to
whichever character takes on the mantle
of black panther after tala few MCU
characters displayed a stronger sense of
Duty and honor than tala you are
wrong all of you are
wrong to turn your backs on the rest of
the world so it seems pretty likely that
he would have honored killmonger's
request and not forced medical
intervention upon the man when he
clearly didn't want it if indeed
kilmonger returns for black panther 2
it's a safe bet that we'll see him on
that that ancestral plane offering his
insight to the New Black Panther who if
fans have anything to say about it might
very well be tala's incredibly
intelligent little sister sh if Marvel
determines that kilmonger is still
miraculously alive then what if he ends
up being the one to become the New Black
Panther at first blush it may seem like
an odd Choice since he was such a
vicious and formidable foe intent on
usurping the throne and using wakandan
technology to dominate the world during
his final battle with tala however he
fought and died with honor and his
motivations were never evil so much as
they were misguided and he's already
worn the Black Panther Garb how
fascinating would it be to see this
complex and righteously angry villain
have the mantle of King that he once
craved now forced upon him to see him
suddenly made to Grapple with his
predecessor's towering Legacy while
being made to cooperate with tala's most
trusted advisers on a daily basis could
he complet a transition over the course
of the film from complicated villain to
reluctant hero it's tough to think of an
act more capable than Jordan of pulling
it off of course we'll be keeping an eye
out for any and all breaking news
regarding black panther 2 and we'll keep
you informed too check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
Looper videos about the MCU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell so you don't miss a
single
[Music]
one